My name is Erik Verlinde.
I work on emergent gravity, and I'm trying
to explain the phenomena associated to dark
matter.
Emergent gravity is a way of describing gravity
which explains where gravity comes from by
thinking about space-time as being built out
of microscopic quantum information.
This quantum information is entangled and
from thinking about the entanglement entropy
we can derive Newton's Law and the Einstein
equations.
But now in the case of our universe, we also
have dark energy.
And what I show is that from dark energy you
can actually explain, using emergent gravity,
what happens in galaxies like galaxy rotation
curves that start flattening, which are normally
explained through dark matter.
Now dark matter is thought of as a particle,
but in my theory there is no particle of dark
matter.
Dark matter is just a phenomena that emerges
from the way that gravity works in our universe.